[Musique]
on m'appelle laurent en kata sami je
suis boulanger au guillaume saint paul
récemment j'ai été titré à la meilleure
baguette de tradition française
tout juste à 25 ans
moi j'étais au lycée evariste de parny
j'ai passé mon bac général et ensuite
après avoir obtenu mon bac général mon
père m'a poussé être boulanger
du coup je me suis renseigné je me suis
inscrit au ca paix a eu ses allures ma
de sainte clotilde et
[Musique]
- tout jeune d'arriver dans ce milieu
c'était sûr que c'était quand même
quelque chose et ensuite j'ai justement
je me suis dit je suis passionné je suis
artisan donc je vais faire ce que j'ai
l'habitude de faire et j'essaierai de
sortir le plus beau produit la
compétition pour moi ma baguette
balaj est meilleur parce que
esthétiquement déjà allé c'était la plus
belle
ensuite à l'intérieur de la baguette
aussi c'était bien aéré bien calibrée
bien grasse bien jeune et c'est sûr que
ça a bien plu au jury
curieux parce que dès que je vois
quelque chose qui me tape à l'oeil ou
que qui m'intéresse moi ça ça me titille
de rechercher un peu plus comment elle
est faite ou bien pourquoi c'est comme
ça et pourquoi c'est qu'on est pas comme
ça donc j'aime bien en fait me poser
plein de questions sur sur les choses
qui m'intrigue
message pour moi ce serait que dawes
parce que la réunion justement je trouve
que on a des jeunes qui on a une
minorité de jeunes qui osent mais on a
pas mal de jeunes qui sont très bons
mais le problème c'est que il ose pas
parce qu'on est loin de tout et ben moi
c'est surtout d'oser ces mots là qui
nous tient à coeur parce qu'on sait qu'à
la réunion il ya de très bon points